we've got triangle a b
c here it looks like a right triangle we
can verify that it is because it
satisfies the pythagorean theorem 8
squared is 64 plus 15 squared is 225 64
plus 225 is 289 which is 17 squared so
it satisfies the pythagorean theorem so
we know we know that this right over
here is a right triangle but what
they're asking us is what is the cosine
of angle abc abc which is this angle
right over here plus 60 degrees
now just like this i don't have any
clear way of evaluating it but we do
have some trig identities in our tool
kit that we could use to express this in
a way that we might be able to evaluate
it in particular we know that the cosine
of a
plus b is equal to the cosine of a times
the cosine of b
minus the sine of a
times
the sine of b so we can do the exact
same thing here with the cosine
the cosine of
angle abc
of angle a
b c
plus
60 degrees this is going to be equal to
let me just write out the whole thing
the cosine of angle abc times the cosine
of 60 degrees
minus the sine of angle abc times the
sine
of 60 degrees so this right over here is
angle a
bc
this is angle a
and this is 60 degrees and this is 60
degrees so let's evaluate each of these
things what is
what is the cosine of angle abc going to
be equal to i'll do that over here the
cosine of angle a b c well we could go
back to sohcahtoa
let me write it down
so
toa cosine is defined as the adjacent
over the hypotenuse cosine is defined as
the adjacent for this angle the adjacent
over the hypotenuse so cosine of angle
abc is equal to 15
over 17. so this right over here is 15
over 17. what is the cosine of 60
degrees
well for there we have to turn back to
our knowledge of 30 60 90 triangles so
if i have a triangle
like this so let me do my best here
construct a 30 60 90 right triangle
so that's a 60 degree side this is a 30
degree side we know and we've seen this
multiple times if the hypotenuse has
length 1 the side opposite the 30 degree
side is one half and the side opposite
the 60 degree side is square root of 3
times this so it's square root of 3
over 2.
so the cosine of 60 degrees if you're
looking at this side right over here and
let me write it let me write it in a
color i haven't used yet so i'm carrying
i care about the cosine of 60 degrees
the cosine
of 60 degrees is going to be equal to
once again adjacent over hypotenuse
one-half over one
is going to be equal to one-half over
one which is equal to one-half
now let's think about the sine
now let's think about the sine of angle
abc
abc so that's this one
right over here so we've already draw we
have our triangle right here sine is
opposite over hypotenuse so opposite is
has length 8 over hypotenuse is 17. so
it's equal to 8 over 17 and then finally
we need to figure out
we need to think about
what the
sine
of 60 degrees is well for at the 60
degree side of this right triangle
opposite over hypotenuse so square root
of 3 over 2 over 1 which is just square
root of 3
over 2. so we have all of the
information we need to evaluate it this
whole thing so this was the sine of 60
degrees this whole thing is going to
evaluate to cosine of angle abc
is 15
over 17 times cosine of 60 degrees is
one-half
so times
one half and then we're going to
subtract sine of abc which is 8 over 17
and then times sine of 60 which is
square root of 3 over 2.
so times square root of 3 over 2 and now
we just have to simplify a little bit
so this is going to be equal to if i
multiply one half times this let's see
it's going to be 15 over 34
15 over 34
minus and let's see we're dividing by 2
so it's 4 17.
i'll write this 4
square roots of 3
over
17. and that's about as simple as i
could do it if i wanted i could some i
could have a common denominator here of
34 and and then i could add the 2 so it
could be 8 square roots of 3 over 32
over 34 but that still won't simplify it
that much so this is a reasonably this
is a reasonable
good answer for what they are asking for
15 over 34 minus 4 square roots of 3
over 17.